and that you play old Deuteronomy and
I'm ready that normally that's been
played by a man is that in the original
yes Brad message okay
and very beautifully but they didn't
need to change it today well I suppose
it doesn't change change the idea that
this is some old kind of clapped-out old
cat the thing is with the CGI you know
you're wearing Greek green leotard and
spots or whatever you and I thought I
knew the kind of cat I was I've had cats
all my life um but when I saw saw saw
myself I suddenly realized I turned into
this this cat I had of my own called
carpet once who is a huge banner or a
loser who are you yes and of course you
get the big number yeah memory man and I
whisper did you back say but when she
does memory how amazing is that it's
just it's so it's just fantastic
and I just wonder in terms of because
the Tom Hooper thing you sing lies yes
right so doing it because when you see
the film I mean you're so emotional
singing that song you're just raw and
racked and yet you are hitting all those
beautiful notes how how hard is that
that was challenging you know because
sometimes sometimes say do you want me
to cry oh you want me the same because I
couldn't do both at the same time so I
had to find a balance to be able to sing
and give you the song but bear the
emotion to yeah you know which could be
challenging but you are just a great big
soggy mess by the end I mean it yeah
yeah cuz Dreamgirls I am Telling You is
another one of those numbers was that
harder than this or is this harder than
that well see with Dreamgirls it was
pre-recorded week at I sang they say
sing the song life with the emotion and
all like 30 times so every time it was
it was more draining from the tears like
singing a song like I could do this all
over again but the emotion that drains
you you know
[Music]